um hi
i'm maria mestre thanks for having me
um so a bit about my background
i did a phd many years ago
working with biomedical signals
and then i moved to industry
where i worked as a data scientist for
more than 10 years
in different companies across different
domains
and recently i started a company with my
co-founder stewart
where we're building an annotation tool
for text and it uses weak supervision
it's called data qa
it has an open source library so we'll
be talking about the open source
app today
um
so
let's just share
so yeah i will be talking about data
enabling with big supervision
um so i'm sure you've heard about it
already data centric ai so it's the new
catchphrase that everybody's talking
about
um
and i think we hear more and more about
it and you know important sort of voices
in the community are also mentioning it
um and i think it's basically because
there's been a recent shift in the focus
from the community where people
um are less you know talking less about
improvements of of you know model
architectures
and more about the
you know
the impact that data has on machine
learning for machine learning
and i think the reason for this is
because um
ai has you know slowly moving or i would
say has moved from academia
into the industry um and now we're
seeing it on you know
it has a rich state of maturity where
we're seeing it
uh used successfully for many different
applications
um and people are starting to realize
that uh you know
you cannot you cannot have a successful
ml
project if you don't have high quality
data
and very often if you're trying to
improve a machine learning model uh you
will get higher gains from improving
your data rather than improving the
model architecture
so yeah just put a few examples of
tweets um of people discussing this
uh last year there was a survey uh
organized by o'reillys
where they were
talking to companies that had deployed
ai or were planning to deploy ai
and
one of the main questions was uh what
were the top challenges today in
adopting ai
uh and the two main challenges were
while struggling to hire the right skill
set um and also
getting the right data like a lack of
data or data quality issues
uh and i would even argue that these uh
two issues are sometimes even linked
because um
what we see is very often the data
scientist at a company is also in charge
of creating the training data and might
end up doing some annotation so spending
a lot of time doing something that might
be better
you know done by a domain expert rather
than the data scientist
and so one last piece of evidence that
the data centric ai is here to stay
so stanford released a
report
recently
with you know trends in industry
and one of the main takeaways was that
some of the benchmarks and
state-of-the-art results that were
achieved
this previous year
were mainly due to
more data getting more data
rather than improvements on the model or
the model architecture
so
with this let me talk now about
oh why is it so hard to get label data
right
well labeling is difficult so depending
also on the application um there might
be some intrinsic ambiguity so that you
know multiple people looking at the same
data they might
come up with different labels
um so you know most labeled data sets
have errors
um and i think many companies they don't
even try to
you know to assess the label the level
of error they have
which i would say is a mistake uh you
know every time you have a label that i
said you should understand
um
what are the errors that you are you're
introducing
um
and yeah there was a study last year
um
about about this so um it's a paper
called pervasive label errors and test
sets the stabilized machine learning
benchmarks so in this paper they looked
at some
data sets that were used for some very
you know famous uh competitions
uh in ai
and they estimated the level of label
error
um and for example imagenet they
estimated around six percent label error
um they even have a website which you
can it's kind of fun so they create this
labelers.com and you can inspect the
different
you know data sets and you will see
some of the examples of errors that you
can find
um
yeah so
labeling data is hard and on top of this
it's a manual error so sorry it's a
manual labor so
it's hard to scale because you need you
know that person looking at the data
now this is where weak supervision is uh
is quite
interesting so
in a
very simplified
process like labeling process you will
have an annotator
look at a bunch of documents
sequentially
and labeling each document one after the
other so it's a linear process it's
non-scalable
you might still end up with you know
some errors at the end
even if a person has checked all the
documents
and there's also if there's a change of
label definition or in the taxonomy
then you might need to start over
and
so it's quite labor intensive and the
only knowledge you get from your
annotator is really those little units
of
um
of knowledge which uh in every time he
labels one document you get a little bit
of information about the problem
uh but you know it's very very linear
very
slow process and
so this is why i'm going to explain to
you now how you would do this with weak
supervision
so wix supervision
is a way to combine uh
like other data sources um
together
so in this case the annotator
the annotator if you know if their
domain expert and they know the data
they will know things about your data
and this you know
with weak supervision they're able to
encode that knowledge
uh in a way that your machine learning
model can also use that knowledge
so things like for example
if there are external data sources or
knowledge bases that are similar to your
problem space
you might be able to use them
you know to pre-annotate your documents
you might you might be able to use
simple explainable rules
so rules about the structure of the
documents rules about syntax um
words that you expect to see
whether there's you know lots of all
caps
punctuation so all sorts of things you
can
you can find you can do
and then you can also combine machine
learning models uh which you might have
trained on a different domain or you
know slightly different
uh data domain
data source
and
you can also use those to pre-annotate
your text
and the idea is that so your annotator
will not only give you
labels for specific documents they will
also give you
uh information about the problem you
know in the
in the format of rules for example
and then
they will label the documents in a way
that you can learn which of these rules
work best
so you might learn for example that
certain knowledge bases work really well
for certain classes
or that for specific documents with
different you know specific structures
there's a rule that works really well
or that if you combine you know assemble
mod you do an ensemble model you have
different weak models you can learn
um that they work really well if one of
them agrees with another one for example
so it's a way of you you get your
annotator to give you some domain
knowledge um in the form of rules
then you add some machine learning layer
to understand which rules work well
and then finally you can automatically
pre-annotate text
you know with a high level of accuracy
and a way to summarize this is so in a
non-machine learning setting where a
person is looking at one document at a
time
um you know for zero effort you have
zero labels and for max effort you have
a hundred percent
label coverage right for your documents
but um if now you add machine learning
or machine learning with wik supervision
so there are different
ways that you can use machine learning
here
but you can achieve a higher level of
accuracy with much less
effort
and you might
depending on the problem you might
decide that you know 80 accuracy 90
increase is enough for your labels
or you might want to have 100 accuracy
but using these techniques will still
speed up
you know um
the labeling effort significantly
so let me now show you an example so the
liquid is an open source tool um it is
written in python the backend is python
the front-end is react
um it combines so a library called
snorkel which
which is for programmatic labeling
uh quite popular library
um so it's built on top of snorkel um
it's built on top of spacey
um so it's you know a rule engine which
uses regular expressions which you can
apply either on the full text or on
spacey tokens
um it also ships with a text search
engine with elasticsearch
and right now um you can do multi-class
classification named entity recognition
or named entity disambiguation
uh and it runs locally okay so you
install it with a pip install
so it's a fairly new project still and
we're still learning what works what
doesn't um but we're really keen on
getting feedback from the community
which is one of the main reasons why i'm
presenting today
um so yeah you can head to the
if you head to the repository you will
see
uh you will see different um
different ways uh yeah so how to install
it we're gonna install with peep
or you can install it with uh run a
docker instead of
click install so there are different
ways you can
you can install it
okay so
now let me show you an example
of what i mean by week with labeling
so i will
show you an example with of a
classification project so here
i have
um
3 000
products from amazon
and i'm trying to
so these are my product description and
i'm trying to annotate them or assign
them a class a product product category
out of 24.
in this case for example this is talking
about a sandal
this would be
clothes clothing shoes and jewelry okay
so
directly has a search engine you can
search you know specific words say i'm
interested in looking at all the
products i have sent all in them and
then you can also label from the
interface
so you know this just label this sandal
this is sandal
so it's a way to quickly generate labels
for specific classes
um especially if you have an imbalanced
data set this works really well because
you might you might
find a way to label the minority class
using a search
uh and then you can add rules so
i'm gonna show you some examples of
rules first
that you can you can use so this is
again in the documentation you have some
examples of rules you can use so
you have regular expressions
which you can apply on the whole text
you can apply on tokens
um you can also apply them on entities
so these are spacey entities so let's
say for example you want to detect all
the organizations
that match this regular expression so
they have american in them
so you will you know american cancer
society for example would be a match
um
and then you can also create rules
that uh take into account the order of
the matches so you might say for example
i will i want to match any document
that talks about the economy so that has
a sentence with a word
you know starting with this regular
expression economy and it's followed by
downturn or growth so too much you know
this specific sentences the economy has
taken a new downturn
um or if you want to do claim detection
you might want to say i want to add any
document i have the name of a person so
any person followed by
say or claim in the same sentence so
here you would be able to match all the
sentences that have this
kind of structure
so in our case
we will create a very simple rule
which says i'm going to copy this is
from the tutorial
very simple which says i'm going to
match any document so if the text
contains
this regular expression so the regular
expression is
if it contains the word book or author
or novel or guide
then i'm going to assign
the label book
so
and the idea here is that uh these rules
if they have a high level of accuracy of
precision
then um you know it's a way to
pre-annotate your your documents and
that way you can when you're manually
reviewing them you should be able to go
much faster
uh so it covered
416
uh product descriptions
and so we can see that you know this one
is correct so say yeah correct
correct correct correct
uh and this way you annotate much faster
than having to you know search the 24
categories
uh and once we add we're thinking of
adding keyboard shortcuts then you know
things should even go much faster than
this
so this is a quick example now i'm going
to show you
let's say that i've done this and then
i've created
many rules so this is the same project
the same data
but now i have you know created 32 rules
okay
um to try to have as much coverage as
possible
um
and so my coverage here is
uh you know around two thousand
documents out of three thousand so two
thirds of my documents are now covered
by rules
um so again these rules are very simple
to come up with because they're just
words um so you you know
you don't need to be
an expert
i mean you just need to understand the
data to be able to come up with them
um
and
so i'm gonna now show you so this is a
notebook that you can also look at it's
in this repository
that i q a notebooks um and uh here uh i
run some experiments i'm not gonna show
you
just every cell
there's a lot of code in here
but i'm just gonna focus on this
in this plot so what i did was um let's
say i had two data sets a training data
set which i used to create my rules and
a test data set which i didn't look at
you know with complete unseen data
um
so i use um here i'm comparing what's
the typical approach a typical approach
is you label some
documents in your training data set you
train a model
and then you go and use that model on
the test data set to you know get some
accuracy
um
and so that's typical approach um so
here whenever i say so ml random manual
n so n is the number of manual labels i
did on the training data set and this is
the accuracy i got on my test set
and this bar here shows you okay what if
um now i used a combination of my manual
labels
as well as the rules
so my training data set now will be much
bigger
it will have a combination of noisy
labels as well as manual labels
and what we've seen for this particular
data set is that there's a significance
a significant improvement in performance
with the same amount of effort in
labeling
and i think there are some studies i
haven't linked to the papers but um this
is you know weak supervision does work
very well
uh
across many applications because the
idea is that
um you give you give
more data to your model and your model
and your model is able to understand
which which are the patterns that work
well and which ones which ones are the
ones that don't work well uh based on
you know the accuracy of each rule
um
so yeah this is for
classification i can also show you
sorry
i'm going to show you an example with
naming entity recognition
so in this case um
okay so my data is i have a thousand
forum posts so let me show you
the data first
um so these are uh it's user generated
content and these are people posting in
a forum talking about side effects of
drugs okay and what i'm trying to do
here is
label all the side effects
that i find okay so my class is a side
effect
um and
in terms of rules we can apply here i'm
going to show you some
some examples
the rules that we support are uh we can
have regular expressions on the entities
if you have like a vocabulary list so
this would be you know you could use
this
um you can tag an entity that appears
after specific words so if you say you
know
i want to tag anything that comes after
married too so obama is married to
michelle obama so you would match that
you can match on phrases
so say i want to tag all the phrases in
documents that have the word ingredients
say like for recipes
or
i want to tag any noun phrase that
matches a list of symptoms
and in this case you won't just match
the you know say
headache or cramp you will match the
entire noun phrase so if you have a
sentence i have experienced mild
headaches it will match the whole noun
phrase mild headache
so let's just run it over our data um
so i'm gonna just copy paste from the
tutorial
that way i don't need to type
so say i have this you know a list of
side effects are pretty common like
headache nausea weight gain dizziness
insomnia so this is my regular
expression
i'm gonna go my data and i'm going to
say i'm going to create a rule
regex match on the entity
and
i'm going to say
this is my
list of side effects
and i want to
give it the class side effects okay so
side effect
uh
word list
i'm gonna create my rule
so what i see is it found um you know
220 documents with these uh with matches
so i can go and then label them see how
well it works
so it says
this sentence says the only side effect
i've ever had was a bad headache okay so
this is correct
did not experience weight gain or any
abnormal side effect that is incorrect
so we can
remove it
um you know became again so this
sentence would have
some missed i mean the rule would not be
able to catch everything
but it did catch nauseated and it found
a sentence that has a bunch of side
effects
so you know you can then
label the missing side effects
okay so that is an example of using
rules for uh named entity recognition
um and at the end
if you go back to the summary table you
can see um you know after you've labeled
some examples you can see what's the
accuracy
and you can go
on this step estimate performance it
will give you the performance of an
entire class across all the rules i
create in this case the position is
around 67
and if you label even more documents it
would give you also a range like a
confidence interval
um
so i think i have time for to also show
you symptom mapping so this is named
entity disambiguation
um
so here
let's say that i have mapped so i have
extracted phrases with all the symptoms
but now i have a taxonomy of symptoms um
and i would like to map it to this
taxonomy okay
um because people might say
i have a headache or i have a migraine
and you might want to map those two
mentions to the same
knowledge base to the same entry in your
taxonomy which would maybe called
headache and migraines i don't know just
to come up with it
so here i have um
i have around 7 000
you know side effects in my taxonomy
um
and i've got you know 50 uh
57 documents or a few documents with 57
mentions of symptoms of sorry side
effects
and i would like to map this mentions to
the um you know the knowledge base
so what i do is i can then i go here and
i can label
i can label them so say
okay i found here that
um
okay my depression has been caused by it
so that's a side effect that was
reported
and these are
the most likely matches in my uh
taxonomy so my taxonomy has 7 000
entries
so it's um
you know do it this manually would would
take a while because there's a lot of
there a lot of entries here
so we do uh here like a matching um
using
just text similarity
but it's it's a way to very quickly be
able to
label
for this problem so moody
like anxious mood for example that would
be your label depressed would also be so
yeah people might say i feel depression
or i am depressed and both should match
to the same entity
cries crying sleep disruptions
uh
i don't know what to say here but um
anyway normal
separately
uh decreased appetite for loss of
appetite and so on
so
these are the types of nlp tasks today
they're um
supported by
um
and
yeah so we're
we also have a
a commercial version of the products um
which we're making changes to the ui
some of these changes will also go to
the open source
um but yeah the commercial uh version of
this product will have you know is
hosted
it has things like user accounts um
authentication uh we support pdfs
we have a machine learning module where
you can train a machine learning based
on your you know given your annotations
um so it has a lot more functionality
than the open source
um so yeah
thank you i don't know why i did this
thank you so much for uh for having me
um so again the open source
link is there data qa uh we're looking
for any feedback
we're looking for contributors as well
um
anything you know this is the reason why
i'm presenting today anything we
we you can tell us about
using this for your problem is really
welcome
and of course if you like it star is
again very very welcome um i put my
email there if you're interested in
talking about
anything and you know about annotations
for your projects uh
we're really open for any discussion any
way we could help you uh we're really
happy to hear from you
and we also have a twitter account where
we are going to tweet a bit more about
programmatic labeling few shot learning
uh all you know all different ways that
you can annotate today and much quicker
yeah
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much maria
so we have time for some questions
the first one is how does it compare to
other data labeling tools like litec or
prodigy
so i cannot speak so much about
like that because i haven't used it
but i think the the focus of this tool
is really the
programmatic labeling bit so it's uh has
a very advanced rule engine which i
showed on the dock so
i'm not sure how you would do this with
other tools so prodigy i know that you
can configure it
um to use it also like you know with
advanced rules um but i think another
difference is the the no code so data qa
really is meant for
you know quick uh data exploration has a
search engine uh you don't there's today
we don't really support developer apis
or any integration with notebooks or
anything like this whereas um
a tool like prodigy has i think a
different end user in mind is really
meant for
a python developer
uh yeah so i think that's the main main
differences
thank you
so the next question is uh what types of
data does data qa support like images or
pdfs i guess you answered that already
for pdfs by now
uh yeah so i mean it's for text so we
don't do anything with images today um
but for text we do we can read pdfs
and um so we would understand the
different sections of the pdf and uh so
yeah you would
find
paragraphs and you can you can apply
rules on a paragraph level on a document
level
great
how do i deal with a selection bias
induced by tools like search
um yeah so selection bias i think um
when you are labeling you you do have to
follow certain principles so for example
one important principle is to label so
let's say you have come up with some
rules um they will
not cover your entire core postmost
probably so you do need to label
uh documents that have not been covered
by the rules you know to understand
something like recall for example um or
you know miss patterns so that's
definitely important um
so and also you need to label
examples of rules so otherwise if you
train a machine learning program
on the on these weak labels without
having annotated any examples from those
weak labels it will not learn which
tools are working and which ones are not
so
this is something yeah i would like to
add to make it easier from the interface
to annotate in a way that we do minimize
the selection bias but this is this is
work in progress
so we have time for one last question
what are your recommendations for
labeling ambiguous cases
so i mean in the use cases i think you
do need to have
either you have like an oracle or i
would say
a person in your company that is the one
that will be the final judge of this
difficult cases uh or um
you know do annotator agreement
type of approach where you have multiple
people look at the same
uh same example and use majority voting
i mean i think those are the only
approaches i know of
okay thank you so much i'd say you can
maybe connect on discord in the kubercyl
channel afterwards if you want to and
thank you very much for the great talk
thank you so much